hi i'm kristen goodwin on this episode
of the fox news rundown the biden
administration says its infrastructure
and broader economic package will help
rein in inflation following the
government revealing its consumer price
index soared 6.2 percent from last year
the biggest 12-month jump since 1990.
fox news sunday host chris wallace
discusses the state of the economy
president biden's agenda and the future
of the gop
surging prices and a supply chain
squeeze causing headaches for american
consumers mark zandy moody's analytics
chief economist shares his thoughts on
high inflation and what can be done to
reverse it plus commentary by former
education secretary betsy devos the fox
news rundown is a daily news podcast
where we take a deeper look at the
stories important to you you can
subscribe on your favorite podcast
player by going to foxnewspodcast.com
i'm charles payne i'm martha mccallum
i'm greg jarrett and this is the fox
news rundown
friday november 12 2021 i'm chris foster
inflation and supply chain problems may
be dragging down president biden's
agenda if we get into
thanksgiving which isn't so far away and
christmas you know when people feel
either one
they can't find the things they want or
two they can't afford or they really
have to squeeze to afford the things
that they can't find that's a lethal
political combination we speak with fox
new sunday host chris wallace i'm lisa
brady we are getting walloped in the
wallet by inflation so is there any end
in sight as the delta wave fades
and the pandemic recedes which you know
hopefully it does then i think inflation
will begin to recede as well
and i'm former education secretary betsy
devos i've got the final word on the fox
news rundown
[Music]
it was announced this week that
inflation is higher than it's been in
nearly 31 years 6.2 percent
year-over-year president biden says it's
supply and demand on the one hand we're
facing new disruptions to our supplies
at the same time we also experience
higher demand for goods because
wages are up as well as as well as
people have money in the bank he says
part of the demand for products will
ease as coronavirus case numbers drop
and people start spending more
disposable income on things like going
out to eat and drink instead of buying
stuff but with just about everything
costing more including food and fuel a
fox news poll finds 9 in 10 voters are
worried about inflation a lot of issues
we talk about don't affect people's
lives in the sense that they experience
it every day inflation does chris
wallace is the host of fox news sunday
every time you go to fill up your car
every time you go to the grocery store
you say man those prices that cost me
more than it used to cost me and you got
to blame somebody and rightly or wrong
and there's a measure of both a lot of
people blame the president and you've
got that one so i think it's tremendous
political hit to the president just in
and of itself but in addition
when part of the problem
is a over demand an overheating of the
economy and the supply can't meet the
demand so the price for everything you
want to get goes up the idea of putting
another 1.75 trillion dollars into the
economy i know that the president says
it's going to help with inflation but
you're going to have a lot of money
being spent sooner than it's paid for it
gets paid for over 8 or 10 years but a
lot of it is being spent faster than
that so you know you just saw with joe
manchin with the comment he put out
yesterday those listeners who took
economics one in college and that i did
take it and it was the worst grade i got
but i remember when you talked about
spending money that was priming the pump
that was you know increasing the flow of
goods and increasing demand and if
you've got demand outstripping supply
which raises prices then putting more
demand pressure into the economy just
seems counterintuitive but i should have
gotten more than
economics don't you think i remember it
maybe you've learned things since um the
buildback better plan at least though is
paid out somewhat over time and there
are some offsets in terms of revenue um
it's the american rescue plan that
pushed all this money into the economy
very very quickly and they just figured
well let's just that's more important
than inflation is but of course the
republicans are still trying to tie are
still trying to tie bill back better to
the risk of even more inflation like you
said
yeah and and you know it is you're
exactly right i mean that was when when
that was passed this last spring that's
when larry summers who's a democrat who
was the treasury secretary to bill
clinton and the top white house economic
adviser to barack obama came out and
said this is just putting 1.9 trillion
unpaid for into the economy
back last spring is that's going to be
inflationary and you had all of these
white house people from the president on
down how many times have we heard i'm
putting together a montage for sunday
transitory how many times did we hear
people over the last six or eight months
say this inflation problem is transitory
well you know life is transitory and
when something is not only going on
six or eight months later but it's
getting worse a half a year later you
know transitory doesn't cut it anymore
and that and that's why i think that
this is a tremendous political hit for
biden and i think it really is going to
endanger
the zeal for passing this 1.7 trillion
dollars in more money yes suppose
supposedly it all adds up i don't
believe it i think that the the costs
are going to end up outstripping the
revenue but in addition it's the the
pace of it what how the money goes out
as opposed to how the money comes in i
think it's going to cause inflationary
pressure
the president has to simultaneously tell
people things are going great my
agenda's working for the economy
but also i understand that you're
struggling to put 90 bucks into your gas
tank so he has this he can't go gloom
and doom but he but he sounds out of
touch if he
just brags
well i thought one of the worst
political lines you know i've been
around a while so you you see whether
politicians handle situations deftly or
not and you know when he was up this
week in baltimore to talk about his
infrastructure plan and one point he's
talking about inflation as you say he's
got a he can't be out of touch he's got
to understand while he's saying that the
economy is doing well that people are
feeling the pain of inflation and he
said can you believe what people are
paying for inflation it's up over four
dollars in california that's not a good
you know he's the president he's
supposed to be in charge he's not
supposed to be a bystander man that car
wreck was just terrible no that's not a
good look for the the the leader of the
free world so
i don't know what they do i mean you
know some of this is is just covered and
the fact that you know
the money's out there and people are
feeling better and so they're spending
more money and as i said the demand is
is uh outstripping the supply because
there are a lot of kinks when you shut
down
an entire economy when you try to reopen
a global economy there are going to be
bottlenecks in the supply chain but he's
got to find some way of dealing with
this you know it is if we get into
thanksgiving which isn't so far away and
christmas you know when people feel
either one they can't find the things
they want or two they can't afford or
they really have to squeeze to afford
the things that they can't find that's a
lethal political combination
yeah um but i just don't know i'm not an
economist i don't even think i took 101
but i don't know what tools presidents
have in their toolbox to take this on i
mean there's the fed the fed stepped in
in the late 70s when inflation was
higher than it is now and eventually you
know you're paying 18 19 for a mortgage
and we're not going to have that
no and and particularly not with
millions of people still unemployed but
you know maybe you do have to pick up
the interest rates you don't pick them
up to 18 or 19 but maybe you have to do
that and
you know i know that this is something
one of the things
now you can hear the philosophy of chris
wallace one of the mistakes that i think
people make in life and actually i talk
to my kids and my wife about this a lot
is recalibrating recalculating you know
how when you're driving and you miss a
turn or something
your gps system will suddenly say
recalculating and you know it'll find a
different route
well sometimes in life you got to
recalculate and say this isn't working
and i'm just not sure at this moment
that spending you know passing arguing
for the next month as he'll have to and
passing
another close to two trillion dollars in
spending i understand some of these
programs are popular you know child care
and free pre-k and all of that stuff and
climate change but man i think that it's
going to make democrats in washington
seem very out of touch with what people
are really worried about in their daily
lives
whatever gets end up getting passed from
buildback better and they have to pass
something they can't go home and say
well we just didn't do anything even if
it's really watered down
the president is going to sign this
infrastructure bill on monday
those two things other than the must
pass spending bills is this just about
it for the democrats getting anything
done before the midterms when they might
lose control of congress
yeah i think so i mean you know you
that's certainly all for this year and
you try to pass a big new
legislative plan i mean look
first of all i can't see them doing
anything more on the budget and so now
you're getting the legislative issues
like you know the budget you can do
through reconciliation in the senate
with just 50 votes the the bare
democratic majority that's a challenge
with mansion and cinema and some others
but when you're talking about
immigration or voting rights or police
reform or any of those other issues uh
now those are legislative and unless
you're going to blow up the filibuster
and i think there is zero appetite i
mean there are people in the senate and
people in the democratic party who want
it but i think that the odds of it
happening are less than zero you just
can't pass it because you're not you
don't have a filibuster majority of 60
votes so i just don't i may be wrong but
i just don't see any substantial
legislation after this year and you're
exactly right look it doesn't take
winning over both the house and the
senate all republicans have to do is win
one because if you let's say they lose
you know they continue not to have the
senate but they do have the house which
seems like the better bet anyway they
can stop any uh biden legislative agenda
in its tracks it for the last two years
of this term because if it doesn't pass
the house doesn't get through congress
well for now the democrats do control
the house and so they have this special
committee investigating the january 6
right at the capitol it looks like
they're going to be getting some trump
white house records against the former
president's wishes and but the subpoenas
so far
have been pretty toothless i guess has
anybody been willing to talk
well supposedly you know and they're not
being advertised by the committee
supposedly some people who worked in the
trump administration are willing to talk
my guess is it's not the people that
were closest to the president and would
have the the greatest sense of what he
was doing in the days leading up to and
actually on the day of january 6. you
know one of the interesting things is
you had steve bannon and it seems to me
his claim to executive privilege is
really weak you know you're talking
about
a former president a guy who wasn't you
know usually when it's when it's
executive privilege it's the president
current president getting advice from a
current administration government
official we're talking about a former
president
invoking executive privilege over
somebody who wasn't even working for him
at the time he was you know in private
life about a completely non-official
duty which was a rally had nothing to do
with his being president
but
at this point the house has voted him in
contempt we'll see what the the justice
department and merrick garland the
attorney general do but so far they've
done nothing and it's been a couple of
weeks so you know time is is flying
because at the end of uh 2022
particularly if the house takes over you
know the republicans take the house they
will end that criminal contempt so if
they're going to move they got to move
fast
the former president's been tearing into
mitch mcconnell again and all the
republicans who voted for infrastructure
in one case to the representatives face
when he promised it didn't happen for
him is there a point where the gop
establishment just cuts ties or is he
now still the republican establishment
no because donald trump about 60 70
percent of the republican base likes
donald trump supports donald trump and
certainly supports him over mitch
mcconnell or liz cheney or anybody else
so you know as long as he's got the
majority of the republican party behind
him and he does
uh he is he's got control over the party
i mean look look i i do find it odd
you've got
infrastructure which became a joke
because
the president trump talked about it so
often and didn't do anything about it
finally they get it passed it's a
bipartisan bill it does a lot of the
things that president trump wanted and
now as you say he's excoriating
republicans like mitch mcconnell or the
republicans in the house who voted for
infrastructure because of the fact that
gives joe biden a win well on the policy
of it it's exactly what donald trump
wanted
fox news sunday host chris wallace good
to talk to you again we'll speak soon
thanks chris
[Music]
this is former education secretary betsy
devos with your fox news commentary
coming up
the surge in prices is lasting longer
than some anticipated including the
federal reserve putting more pressure
not only on the fed and the white house
to act but on democratic lawmakers
california congressman rokhana telling
fox's neil cavuto i'm hearing it from my
constituents that
prices have gone up and we can't just
wish this away but he defends the
president's agenda as part of the
solution while georgia congressman and
deputy house minority whip drew ferguson
tells fox business americans know that
the inflation is being driven by the
policies of the by administration
we know this people are talking about it
five dollar gas three times cost for
turkeys if you can find it he and other
republicans argue that government
decisions helped create the problem
contributing to a labor shortage and
that more government spending will only
make it worse the fed chief said
recently that supply chain issues could
keep inflation elevated well into next
year well it means we're all paying a
lot more for the same stuff
mark zandy is chief economist at moody's
analytics just a little bit of a
calculation
would show that the average
american household is probably spending
about
200 more a month uh now than a year ago
to buy the same
food the same gasoline the same
everything uh so 200 bucks you know for
the typical american household
you know that's a cable bill that's an
electric bill
that's that's meaningful so it's cutting
into our standard of living the
president is blaming a lot of this on
increasing demand for goods and
basically saying you know the economy
has improved so much people have more
money to spend
almost suggesting it's kind of a good
problem to have
um
how much of that is true in your mind
what's really driving this
yeah i think it's about the pandemic
the delta wave in particular it did a
lot of damage
to global supply chains you know delta
hit us hard but it hit asia particularly
southeast asia very hard and that's
where all these supply chains begin
it scrambled the labor market you know
many more people got sick because of
delta and didn't couldn't go to work or
they had to take care of sick people or
they were fearful of getting sick so
that made it difficult to fill a lot of
open positions caused wage growth to
accelerate and of course businesses pass
that along to customers so uh to my mind
you know what's going on here is the
pandemic
which if you buy into that if you think
that diagnosis is correct then as the
delta wave fades
and the pandemic recedes which you know
hopefully it does
then i think inflation will begin to
recede as well but i think it's mostly
about the pandemic that is something the
white house has talked a lot about as
well that it is you know largely blamed
on pandemic related issues
certainly when we first came out of
lockdown because things had been locked
down there wasn't as much supply to
begin with and then as you noted the
delta wave comes along
and kind of disrupts things again
one thing i think about though is the
fact that during lockdown and as we were
coming out of it too we you know there
was a lot of online ordering for
instance
um
and yet we didn't see ships lined up at
california ports
it sort of happened later do you know
what i mean so i think that's that's a
little confusing to me can you explain
that was it just a snowball effect it
took a while for it to build up well i
think it's the
the delta wave hitting asia particularly
hard i mean i'll give you an example the
f-150 truck is the most popular truck in
the united states and uh all the
semiconductors all the chips that go
into that truck and there are a lot of
them get sourced from a couple malaysian
chip plants and the malaysian chip
plants were shut down by the malaysian
government
during the delta wave a few months ago
as part of you know their zero covet
policy so in a lot of asia including
malaysia
they have a policy if they see any
coveted whatsoever they shut everything
down and that's what they did so you
couldn't get the chips the f-150
couldn't get produced you see these
severe shortages of
of vehicles and trucks and vehicle
prices go skyward and that's one of the
reasons why
consumer price inflation
saw such high rates of inflation so
that's just an example china same thing
they in this case they shut down ports
they found covet among
some workers in some of the terminals
and the major ports in shenzhen and
shanghai they shut those down but
completely shut them down you know
literally shut them down and of course
that scrambles everything throughout the
global supply chain so those are just a
couple of examples delta also really did
a lot of damage to
the labor markets i mean uh we we didn't
have the same number of open job
positions back year year and a half ago
we got the vaccines and then every
business felt like in the country put up
a helpline sign at the same time
and you know they want to do business
and uh but of course people are getting
sick more people got sick there's
two more million more people out of work
in october compared to september
because of uh of covid and that and that
is an improvement over what was it
happened in september because delta's
starting to wind down but you know
that's a lot of those open positions
just can't get filled so delta the the
just the nature of it i think uh is
behind uh you know what we're observing
in supply chains and labor markets today
there's also an argument that the
government spending more money
is just going to make inflation
worse
can you
walk us through kind of the two sides of
that argument
well i think the thought is that you
know if the government provides a lot of
stimulus then uh that's demand and if
demand
is rising quickly and bumps up against
limited supply you get inflation you
know price increases
uh i don't think that's what's going on
here i mean the american rescue plan
that was passed back and implemented
beginning back in march
and that
supported demand you know in the first
quarter going into the second but by the
third quarter the support has faded in
fact q3 growth was was weak again
because of delta delta did
a lot of damage to growth i mean gdp
that's the value of all the things that
we produce the growth in that came to a
virtual standstill
consumer demand was very soft so it's
hard to connect the dots between the
american rescue plan and this inflation
it you know it's much more logical to
conclude as i have that it's you know
the delta you know doing damage here so
i don't think we can draw any lessons
from the ar the american rescue planet
and current inflation and say hey that
means that you know if we pass the
buildback better agenda which by the way
is
uh next year and the year after and the
year after that but that's going to add
to inflationary pressures and i don't i
don't think that it will
you know i think that the bill back
better legislation is more about
long-term economic growth
we've heard the word transitory a lot
when it comes to inflation from both the
fed and the biden administration
the fed has seemed to acknowledge though
that
already inflation's kind of
hotter than they had expected it to be
for longer if you will
is would you still describe it as
transitory
well it doesn't that doesn't resonate
with people right because so probably no
i mean
only an economist would appreciate that
term i think i mean it doesn't feel
transitory so no i don't think i'd
describe it that and i don't think this
is going to be this is you know these
problems and supply chains and labor
markets iron themselves out you know
quickly i mean you know the metaphor i
have in my mind is
you know you have this jigsaw puzzle and
uh you're trying to put the puzzle
together and the only thing you have in
the beginning is the picture on the box
that's really painful to get to you know
get the border in place and get those
first pieces together because you know
you don't have context you don't have
any anything to go on that's the supply
chain right now so getting those pieces
in place in the beginning are going to
be slow going it's going to take some
time but you know once you got the frame
in and some of those pieces in the last
half of the puzzle comes a lot more
quickly right because you've got context
you've got you've got some pieces to
work with and i think that's how the
supply chain is going to resolve itself
here you know i think we're seeing the
worst of it now but the next three six
months is going to be slow going but you
know
by the by next spring summer things will
really get back starting to get back
into place and i think by this time next
year if the pandemic sticks to script
and continues to recede
we're not going to be talking about
supply chains we're not going to be
talking about inflation i also wanted to
ask you quickly about the comparisons
that have been made between what's
happening now in the 1970s um you know
what's different what's what is similar
in terms of the rising prices and the
state of the economy
back in the 70s and 80s and we didn't
have an inflation problem was uh we got
into a
wage so-called wage price spiral where
wage growth accelerated
businesses
were able to pass the higher wages onto
their customers in the form of higher
prices
workers saw the higher prices and said
you've got to pay me higher wages you
can see how you get into this kind of
self-reinforcing kind of negative
dynamic
inflationary spiral we were in that
situation back then
and moreover
inflation expectations you know the what
people expected inflation to be in the
future also rose quite significantly
uh and you know once that happens you
that also reinforces that you know kind
of negative wage price spiral
so we were kind of trapped in that
be probably beginning late 60s
throughout most of the 70s of course all
that got exacerbated by the oil price
shocks of those the oil embargoes of
that period uh and we really didn't
break that cycle until the early 90s
that when inflation was as high as it is
today we don't have that same dynamic
today i mean wages are up
uh
but that goes again back to the to the
pandemic and it's mostly for low-wage
workers where the labor shortages are
most significant and i suspect as the
pandemic fades and people get back to
work we'll see that wage growth moderate
we've also seen a pickup in productivity
growth which is very encouraging because
you know for a business person
you know they can increase productivity
that means they can produce the same
amount of things
with less
less labor hours and so even if the cost
of labor goes up their overall cost
doesn't and so their margins are fine
their profitability is fine and there's
less pressure on them to raise prices
uh and then of course inflation
expectations have not risen yet to any
significant degree and that's why
from when you go back to the question of
is this transitory if you ask an
economist or a fed official that
question they say yeah this is
transitory and the reason they say that
is because inflation expectations have
not yet risen so they don't believe like
i don't believe that this is going to be
a persistent problem uh it's not going
to be endemic we're not going back to
the 70s and 80s this is a temporary
problem but you know again temporary
uh you know for from from most americans
mean you know uh that means next month
i'm gonna be paying less than i'm paying
today that's not what i'm saying but you
know from an economist perspective that
that would be considered temporary
transitory so in general you're
optimistic i guess if we want to try to
leave it on a positive note i i am i i
mean i i'll go so far to say as i think
inflation's we're seeing the worst of
the inflation right now i mean i i to be
frank i was surprised by the
increase in inflation in october it was
more than i expect i knew it was going
to be an ugly report i knew we're going
to get high inflation but that was hard
to look at and the the broad-based
nature of the price increases surprised
me also but you know i chalked that up
to the vagaries of data you know i look
at data all day long
and we're always surprised because you
know
it's data you know there's all kinds of
noise in the data and timing issues and
everything else but my fundamental take
on things is the same and that is the
pandemic is behind this as the pandemic
recedes assuming it does and i think
that's the best forecast and this
inflation will receive so yeah i'm
optimistic mark zandy chief economist
with moody's analytics thanks as always
for your time
oh thank you i really appreciate the
opportunity
[Music]
hey it's brett larsen inviting you to
download and listen to the new daily fox
on tech podcast there's part of a
colorful late 90s imac on mars it's an
idea that seems a lot like kickstarter
called build it subscribe and listen now
by going to foxnewspodcast.com or
wherever you get your podcasts raiden
review the fox news rundown on apple
podcasts or wherever you listen
and now some good news with tanya j
powers
[Music]
dr manfred steiner has reached a goal
that he spent two decades working toward
and nearly a lifetime thinking about he
earned a phd from brown university and
became a physicist that's an impressive
feat in itself but add to that the fact
that it's his third doctorate and he's
89. dr steiner has had a successful
career as a doctor helping lots of
students learn about blood and blood
disorders he told the associated press
that he'd always been interested in
physics even as far back as his
childhood when he retired in 2000 at the
age of 70 he started attending
undergraduate lectures at mit then brown
he said he didn't really set out to earn
a phd it just sort of happened dr
steiner says he took classes to keep his
mind sharp taking a class or two each
semester so he could spend time with his
grandchildren and his wife sheila who's
93. they've been married since 1960. by
2007 he had finished the requirements to
enter grad school where he was admitted
to the phd program
he defended his dissertation in
september after recovering from a
serious medical condition
and he's not done either next he plans
to work with one of his advisors on a
paper they plan to publish which would
make him not only one of the oldest
people to earn a phd in physics but one
of the oldest published physicists
dr steiner has some advice for the rest
of us
do what you want to do
he told npr don't give up on it if it
doesn't work out you can always do
something else but first follow your
dream
tanya j powers fox news
[Music]
it's time for your fox news commentary
betsy devos
what's on your mind there's the
potential for a new fault line in
america's ever-growing debate about
parental rights
a schism between policymakers who
believe parents have a right to know
what's being taught in public k-12
schools and those who do not
wisconsin lawmakers recently passed
overwhelmingly the nation's first most
powerful academic transparency law to
pull back the curtains on the content of
classroom instruction
the bill requires schools to post online
a listing of the specific instructional
materials being presented
so that current and prospective parents
can see for themselves whether the
content awaiting their kids is
academically rigorous or ideologically
extreme
it remains to be seen if wisconsin's
governor tony evers will take his veto
pen to this common sense measure or not
this comes on the heels of real threats
to parents innate rights to raise their
children in the way they see fit getting
the national spotlight the biden
administration likened vocal parents
demanding the best for their kids to
agents of domestic terrorism union
bosses and their media allies have made
clear parents should have no control
over where when or how their kids learn
now the actual content of curriculum is
again taking center stage
in theory state laws across the country
already affirm parents rights to access
the instructional materials used in the
classroom but after the wisconsin
institute for law and liberty revealed
some wisconsin school districts were
demanding as much as five thousand
dollars to respond to simple public
records requests about content in a
handful of courses at a handful of
schools state lawmakers recognize that
the vague assurances currently on the
books offer parents no meaningful rights
at all similar tales are playing out
across the nation in response states as
diverse as north carolina arizona
illinois texas and wyoming have already
filed or advanced academic transparency
legislation this year because wokeness
is the left's religion banning critical
race theory or the 16-19 project won't
fix the problem the liberal education
establishment will simply rename rebrand
or repackage these insidious ideas to
get around so-called bans
instead we must equip parents themselves
with the tools to hold schools
accountable for their programming
decisions
to be able to see what is being taught
and differentiate between activists
and academically oriented schools before
they have to make an enrollment decision
schools in turn will find themselves
under a meaningful spotlight for the
first time
and those that don't want to alienate
prospective parents and the substantial
funding formula that comes with their
kids enrollment may finally have an
incentive to veer away from political
extremism on their own
educators around the country have
expressed their support for academic
transparency legislation pointing out
that teachers already commonly submit
their lesson plans to their principles
or already keep track of the materials
they assign in order to reuse them the
next year
so there is little reason this
information needs to be kept under lock
and key but of course that hasn't
stopped the education blob
indeed as if in a contest to out
dramatize each other union allies have
branded curricular transparency efforts
as bullying and censorship fascism
teacher abuse intimidation and
harassment a conspiracy to prevent
students from learning honest history
hiding materials taught to children from
their own parents seems a line
politicians should be wary to cross
we'll see if their union funders push
them to cross it i'm former education
secretary betsy devos author of the
upcoming book hostages to the cause the
fight for education and the future of
the american child
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com and for up to the
minute news go to foxnews.com
from the fox news podcasts network i'm
ben dominic publisher of the federalists
and i'm inviting you to join a new
conversation with the smartest thinkers
out there about the country and where
we're going subscribe to the ben dominic
podcast subscribe and listen now by
going to foxnewspodcast.com
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust and click the fox news rundown
playlist for the latest episodes